[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen viel
Fußball gleich von Norbert Lehmann
und das sind unsere großen Themen
47 gegen Putin der europa-gipfel im
bedrohten Moldau sendet eine deutliche
Botschaft an Russland
was wird aus Deutschlands Kliniken im
Streit und die krankenhausreformen
kommen sich Bund und Länder näher
und die Bahn auf brüchigem Grund
bröselnde Betonschwellen ließen den Zug
in Garmisch-Partenkirchen in Gleisen
jetzt werden 100.000 ausgetauscht
[Musik]
fast ganz Europa hat sich heute zu einem
solidaritätsgipfel getroffen um sich
hinter den Nachbarstaaten Russlands zu
stellen der Gipfel fand in Moldau statt
nicht weit von der ukrainischen Grenze
die europäische politische Gemeinschaft
kurz EPG hat sich vor knapp acht Monaten
zum ersten Mal getroffen als Reaktion
auf den russischen Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine zur EPG gehören die 27
EU-Staaten sowie 20 weitere europäische
und forderasiatische Staaten insgesamt
sind es 47 Länder aus Moldau berichtet
Sebastian
der Termin der am Mittag in der
prächtigen Kulisse des Schloss Mimi
stattfindet nennt sich Familienfoto und
die europäische Familie nimmt sowohl den
ukrainischen Präsidenten selensky als
auch die moldauische Staatschefin Meier
Sando in ihre Mitte die Botschaft
eindeutig wir lassen die Ukraine und
Moldau nicht allein doch mit schönen
Gipfel Bildern will sich der ukrainische
Präsident nicht mehr zufriedengeben
silenski erhöht den Druck
wenn nicht einmal die Ukraine die die
Werte und die Freiheit Europas mit ihrem
Blut verteidigt eine klare positive
Antwort für einen EU und NATO-Beitritt
bekommt werden die Hoffnungen alle
anderen Kandidaten komplett
illusorisch
auch Gastgeberland Moldau will in die EU
das kleine Land ist schon seit längerem
im Fokus des Grimmel russland versucht
die Republik Moldau gezielt zu
destabilisieren Präsidentin Meier Sand
du weißt dass viel davon abhängt wie
sich der Krieg in der Ukraine
weiterentwickelt
heute gesagt wir werden so lange wie
nötig an der Seite der Ukraine stehen
als Präsidentin moldaus weiß ich dass
ohne den Widerstand und den Mut der
Ukraine mein eigenes Land bedroht wäre
die EU hat für Moldau heute frisches
Geld und Hilfe bei der cyberabwehr im
Gepäck doch was konkrete Garantien an
die Ukraine anbelangt hält sich Olaf
Scholz bedeckt wir haben immer gesagt
dass es auch für eine Friedensordnung
nach dem Krieg Garantien geben muss und
da wird Deutschland ein Beitrag leisten
wie die ganz konkret aussehen das wird
etwas sein dass wir zu besprechen haben
die europäische politische Gemeinschaft
präsentiert sich heute als große Familie
es ist ein Gipfel mit wenig
Entscheidungen und großer politischer
Symbolik
und Roller in Moldau bleibt von diesem
Gipfel denn mehr als Symbolik
also natürlich hat es hier nicht die
großen Entscheidung gegeben aber das war
ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht die
Erwartung und man sollte die Symbolik
dieses Gipfel wirklich nicht
unterschätzen der Ukraine Krieg wird ein
Langstreckenlauf das ist immer wieder
deutlich geworden und da ist es
entscheidend dass man durchhält und
deswegen ist diese Solidarität die heute
wieder gezeigt wurde mit der Ukraine und
die immer wieder öffentlich erneut
gezeigt werden muss ganz wichtig das ist
ein zeichenrichtung Moskau dass man eben
sagt wir werden nicht müde Rechte nicht
damit dass der Westen schwach wird und
dann ist doch eine zweite Botschaft es
war ja ein riesengipfel mit fast 50
Regierungschefs die doch teilweise sehr
unterschiedlich sind manche sind sogar
Putin verstehe aber in einer Frage ist
man doch sehr sehr geschlossen nämlich
dass dieser Angriffskrieg Russland nicht
geht und damit ist auch sehr deutlich
geworden wie isoliert putin ist danke
für diese Einschätzung
der ukrainekrieg war auch ein großes
Thema beim informellen Treffen der
nato-außenministerin und Minister heute
in Oslo alle NATO-Staaten seien sich
einig dass die Ukraine den Bündnis
beitreten werde sofort müsse aber
sichergestellt werden dass die Ukraine
den russischen Angriffskrieg überlebe
sagte NATO Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
über das aktuelle Kriegsgeschehen
Berichte Tim Krüger
die Raketen kamen wie so oft in der
Nacht rissen Menschen aus dem Schlaf die
sich in ihren Badezimmern Bunkern oder
Schutzräumen in Sicherheit bringen
mussten drei Menschen starben hier
darunter ein Kind durch einen Einschlag
in der Nähe eines Krankenhauses dieser
Anwohner verlor seine Frau bei der
Attacke
wir haben versucht in den Bunker zu
gehen aber niemand hat geöffnet in dem
Moment sind Wrackteile der Rakete oder
die Rakete selbst runtergekommen da
waren Menschen Frauen Kinder meine Frau
wurde getötet
jetzt wird untersucht was genau
geschehen ist ob und warum der
Schutzraum offenbar verschlossen war der
russischen versuchen eine depressive
Laune an uns zu bringen stattdessen
sehen sie wollte der vergangene Mai war
der Monat mit den meisten Raketen und
Drohnenangriffen seit Kriegsbeginn jetzt
scheint diese massive Angriffswelle auch
im Juni weiterzugehen diese Bilder
sollen zeigen dass das zeitgleich erneut
die russische Region Belgorod an der
Grenze zur Ukraine angegriffen wurde
auch dabei soll es Verletzte gegeben
haben von 3 bis 7 Uhr morgens konnten
wir nicht weg wir mussten unsere Köpfe
unten halten es war beängstigend
eine paramilitärische antirussische
Gruppierung hatte in einem Video weitere
Angriffe angekündigt und diese
drohnenaufnahmen veröffentlicht das
russische Militär sprach von einer
versuchten Invasion mit gepanzerten
Fahrzeugen drei Angriffe auf russisches
Territorium sein aber abgewehrt worden
nach Deutschland und der Frage wie sieht
die Zukunft der Kliniken aus Bund und
Länder kommen bei der krankenhausreform
voran sagt Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach und spricht schon von einem
Durchbruch allerdings lehnen die Länder
den Plan ab die Kliniken in drei Gruppen
einzuteilen
unumstritten ist dagegen ein neues
Finanzierungsmodell um wirtschaftlichen
Druck von den Kliniken zu nehmen
Einzelheiten von innen
ein Krankenhaus wie so viele die
warnow-klinik in Bützow
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern 70 Betten vier
Abteilungen klein und doch viel im
Angebot Kliniken wie diese 70% aller
Kliniken schreiben seit Jahren rote
Zahlen Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
warnt komme seine krankenhausreform
nicht durch dann könnte jede vierte
Klinik sterben es war sehr viele
Krankenhause sind existenziell jetzt
bedroht können ohne die Reform nicht
klar kommen wir haben somit daneben
einander von qualitätsdefiziten aber
auch eine versorgungs-
eine Deutschlandkarte die die Qualität
eines jeden Krankenhauses aufzeigt sein
Ziel in drei Stufen sollen Kliniken
eingeteilt und entsprechend vergütet
werden je nachdem welche Leistungen sie
bieten Maximalversorger wie Unikliniken
an der Spitze im mittleren Bereich
regionale Fachkliniken dazu die
wohnortnahe Grundversorgung komplizierte
Ops sollen künftig den spezialisierten
Zen en vorbehalten sein die Länder aber
gehen bei der Einteilung nicht mit sie
fürchten das kleine Kliniken auf dem
Land dicht machen werden und sehen
Lauterbach Plan als Eingriff in ihre
Planungshoheit die Länder haben den Hut
auch in der Krankenhausplanung
das ist unser Job und wir wollen auch
keine bundesschablone für Krankenhäuser
es geht auch verfassungsrechtlich gar
nicht anders für mich ist es wichtig
dass die Menschen in den ländlichen
Räumen gut und qualitätsvoll versorgt
werden und Versorgung kein Privileg der
Metropole ist
unumstritten dagegen der zweite
Kernpunkt der Reform finanzieren sollen
sich die Krankenhäuser nur noch zu 40
Prozent aus Fallpauschalen der Bezahlung
pro Behandlung 60% ihrer Mittel sollen
künftig aus vorhaltepauschalen kommen
dafür dass sie Leistungen vorhalten
Lauterbach spricht heute von Durchbruch
doch beim zentralen Teil seiner Reform
der Einteilung der Kliniken in Stufen
ist er sich mit den Ländern nicht einig
die geplante klinikreform bei uns können
Sie online noch mal alle wichtigen
Aspekte nachlesen von der Fallpauschale
über die drei Stufen bis hin zur Kritik
von Bundesländern wir erklären es kurz
und knapp in unserer ZDF heute App
wie konnte es zu dem tödlichen
Zugunglück vor fast einem Jahr in
Garmisch-Partenkirchen kommen fünf
Menschen waren dabei ums Leben gekommen
schadhafte Betonschwellen hätten dazu
geführt dass der Zug entgleiste das
stellt ein heute veröffentlichter
Zwischenbericht fest die Einzelheiten
von Axel Konrad
der dritte juni 2022 um kurz nach 12
entgleist der Regionalzug bei Garmisch
vier Frauen und ein 13-Jähriger sterben
mehr als 78 Menschen werden zum Teil
schwer verletzt die Ermittlungen der
Unfallursache sind schwierig das
Gleisbett von der 83 Tonnen schweren
Lokomotive völlig zerstört der
Zwischenbericht verzögert sich um ein
halbes Jahr und bestätigt jetzt seinen
Verdacht in die Bahn schon von Beginn an
hatte die an dieser Stelle verlegten
spannbeton-schwellen in diesen
Beschädigungen auf diese führten in der
Folge zu einem Versagen der Strukturen
zum Wegbrechen der schienenauflage
die Bahn hat bereits zehntausende
Schwellen ausgetauscht bei Schwellen
eines bestimmten Bautyps und Herstellers
waren Unregelmäßigkeiten im Material
festgestellt worden es zersetzt sich von
innen fachleute sprechen von betonkrebs
480.000 Betonschwellen will die Bahn
insgesamt austauschen
wir haben ja schon begonnen Schwellen
auszutauschen wir werden noch mehr
Schwellen austauschen müssen als das
ursprünglich geplant war das bedeutet
natürlich mehr Baustellen etwa 400
zusätzliche Baustellen in unserem Netz
und das wo die Bahn ohnehin im
Sanierungsstau steckt jetzt noch mehr
Baustellen auf den 33.000
Schienenkilometer für die Fahrgäste
bedeutet dass das sehr viele
kurzfristige Baustellen kommen werden
die Bahn kriegt schon bei ihren
geplanten Baustellen nicht in die
Fahrpläne rechtzeitig zu veröffentlichen
das heißt wir müssen damit rechnen dass
der Fahrplan von morgen kurzfristig
geändert wird das heißt man muss
wirklich immer vor der Fahrt nachschauen
fährt mein Zug weil plötzlich Baustellen
auftreten können die Betroffenen
Schwellen sind im gesamten deutschen
Streckennetz verbaut besonders betroffen
aber so die Bahn sind Sachsen-Anhalt und
Thüringen
einem Monat gibt es das
deutschland-ticket mit dem man für 49
Euro im Monat bundesweit den nah und
Regionalverkehr nutzen kann das Ticket
kommt bei vielen gut an FDP
Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing spricht
von einem riesen Erfolg aber es gibt
auch Kritik so fordert die SPD Wissing
zu einem vergünstigten Deutschland
Ticket für Studierende auf eine erste
Bilanz des Tickets von Peter Theisen
kreuz und quer durch Deutschland für
nicht einmal 50 Euro für viele offenbar
ein interessantes Angebot meine
Erfahrungen sind durchaus positiv weil
man für kleines geldführung kommt für
mich kommt es weniger meistens auf die
Zeit an sondern mehr auf den Preis und
dafür ist es eine gute Möglichkeit
generell finde ich es gut ich bin auch
jemand der kein Problem hat wenn die
Bahn mal Verspätung hat weil man steht
genauso mit dem Auto im Stau wie mit der
Bahn der Ansturm auf das 49 € teure
deutschland-ticket ist zwar nicht so
groß wie auf das 9 € Ticket dennoch die
Bahn freut sich über 10 Millionen
verkaufte Tickets von den 10 Millionen
sind 700.000 Fahrgäste die bislang noch
gar nicht Nahverkehr gefahren sind und
die jetzt neu dazu gekommen sind und die
dann möglicherweise ihr eigenes Auto
jetzt stehen lassen doch es gibt auch
Kritik das Versprechen einer
klimafreundlichen Verkehrswende für alle
das können die Bahn in ihrem derzeitigen
Zustand gar nicht erfüllen die
Erweiterung der Züge
Personals und auch der Ausbau der
Strecken das muss jetzt sehr schnell
passieren denn eigentlich hat man mit
diesem Ticket das Pferd vom Schwanz her
aufgezäumt man hätte eigentlich erst die
bessere Infrastruktur haben müssen
dennoch einige Experten halten das
deutschland-ticket für eine Revolution
nur auf dem Land müsste das Angebot
deutlich ausgebaut werden und sobald wir
auch im ländlichen Raum ganz viele
moderne innovative Bussysteme einführen
landbusse dann ist das natürlich auch
sehr relevant für die Pendler die leider
im ländlichen Raum im Moment überwiegend
im Auto sitzen zurzeit ist das
deutschlandticket vor allem für Pendler
in den Ballungsräumen interessant und
für Urlauber wer möchte der kann diesen
Sommer unschlagbar günstig durch ganz
Deutschland reisen
in die USA die sind nach dem
Schuldenstreit einen wichtigen Schritt
weiter um eine drohende
Zahlungsunfähigkeit der Regierung
abzuwenden denn das Repräsentantenhaus
hat dem Deal von Republikanern und
Demokraten zugestimmt mit großer
Mehrheit stimmten die Abgeordneten für
einen Gesetzentwurf mit dem die Schulden
Obergrenze bis 2025 ausgesetzt werden
soll zugleich soll es für den Staat ein
Sparkurs geben nun muss auch der Sinn
hat noch zustimmen
in Kanada wüten weiter Waldbrände in der
Provinz Alberta im Westen sind mehr als
eine Million Hektar abgebrannt eine
Fläche viermal so groß wie das Saarland
und auch im Osten Kanadas sind
Waldbrände außer Kontrolle der
Regierungschef der Provinz Nova Scotia
spricht von einer beispiellosen
Katastrophe tausende Menschen mussten
ihre Häuser verlassen Johannes Hano
berichtet
kanadische
mittlerweile was ich in Kanadas Wäldern
gerade abspielt von Alberta im Westen
bis an die Ostküste wie hier bei Harry
Faxe Nova Scotia riesige Waldbrände
allein in Nova Scotia mussten in den
letzten Tagen etwa 16.000 Menschen
evakuiert werden mehr als 200 Gebäude
sind in Flammen schon zum Opfer gefallen
150 davon Wohnhäuser
Zeit und es wird doch noch länger
andauern wir versuchen das Feuer
einzudämmen aber mit jedem Tag an dem es
nicht regnet und die Temperaturen
ansteigen und der Windstärke wird wird
die Situation immer volatiler
nur was Gosche hat wie fast alle
Provinzen mit ungewöhnlicher Trockenheit
zu kämpfen die Niederschläge Schnee und
Regen liegen seit vielen Monaten
deutlich unter dem was sie hier sonst
gewohnt sind Wälder und Böden
ausgetrocknet ich habe mit einem unserer
Leute gesprochen und er hat mir erzählt
dass man die Blut zwar ausstampfen kann
aber in dem Moment wo man geht entflammt
alles wieder wir brauchen sehr viel
Wasser es ist sehr sehr trocken
und Regen ist nicht in Sicht im
Gegenteil die nächsten Tage soll es
wärmer und noch weniger werden mehr als
200 Quadratkilometer Waldbränden schon
jetzt allein in Nova Scotia bis weit in
den Süden in die USA hinein liegt ein
rauchschleier in der Luft für Teile von
New Jersey und Pennsylvania wurde
smokeralarm ausgelöst und auch in New
York City ist der Rauch zu spüren
die UNO will eine gewaltige
Umweltkatastrophe vor der Küste des
Jemen verhindern deshalb hat sie eine
Bergungsaktion für einen schrottreifen
Öltanker gestartet das Schiff dient seit
Jahrzehnten als schwimmendes Öllager und
hat mehr als eine Million Barrel Öl
geladen wegen des Bürgerkriegs in Jemen
wurde es lange nicht mehr gewartet und
droht auseinander zu brechen mit
verheerenden Folgen für das Rote Meer
und die Küsten die UNO will nun das Öl
auf einen zweiten Tanker Umpumpen
die zdf-journalistin Eigendorf ist mit
dem Walter Lübcke demokratie-preis
ausgezeichnet worden er würdigt
Persönlichkeiten die für Werte stehen
die auch der von einem Rechtsextremisten
ermordete Kassler Regierungspräsident
verkörperte durch ihre mutigen
Reportagen verschaffe Katrin Eigendorf
den Opfern von Krieg und Vertreibung
gehört so die Begründung der hessischen
Landesregierung die den Preis ausgelobt
hat
und willkommen zur Fußball Europa League
Norbert da hat sie wer ja schon wieder
das Finale gemacht zum vierten Mal in
der Vereinsgeschichte ein geradezu
episches Endspiel gestern Abend den
Budapest gegen die AS Rom mit
Verlängerung und Elfmeterschießen und da
hatten die Spanier bessere Nerven und
vor allem bessere schützen
die Europa League ist die Serie Liga
Titeln spanische Zeitungen heute und das
mit Recht im Unrecht fühlt sich Roms
Erfolgstrainer Joseph Mourinho mehr als
einmal und giftet gegen Schiedsrichter
Anthony Taylor aus England so eine
referie bei so einem wichtigen Spiel das
ist wirklich die Härte
dura dabei ist Rom zunächst den Vorteil
geht mit dem 1:0 durch Paulo die Wahler
in die Pause mourinos Reaktion konträr
zum Rest des Teams doch den als
defensivkünstlern bekannten Römern
unterläuft ein Schnitzer der Ausgleich
ein Eigentor von Gianluca Mancini torlos
die Verlängerung die Oma dann jedoch mit
zwei verschossenen versuchen im
Elfmeterschießen Matchball Sevilla
montiell verschießt zunächst Täler
gewährt ihm aber eine Wiederholung weil
der Torwart sich zu früh bewegt haben
soll der Rest ist europa-pokalgeschichte
Sevilla schreibt darin sein eigenes
Kapitel
[Applaus]
gestern Abend ein episches Fußball
Finale heute Nachmittag ein episches
Tennismatch in Paris nach fast
fünfeinhalb Stunden besiegte Außenseiter
Daniel Altmeyer den Weltranglisten 9
Janik Sinner aus Italien sensationell in
drei zu zwei Sätzen und Anna-Lena
Friedsam dagegen steht als letzte
deutsche Einzelspielerin im Grand Slam
Turnier Aussee unterlag der Russen die
Katharina Alexandra
ja nach wochenlang Spekulation steht
jetzt fest Weltfußballer Lionel Messi
verlässt Paris St Germain zum Saisonende
ein neuer Arbeitgeber könnte in
Saudi-Arabien sein
das heutige Training von Paris St
Germain dürfte das letzte mit Lionel
Messi gewesen sein morgen ist ein
Abschiedsspiel im Park de brass und er
sollte mit großem Applaus empfangen
werden vor zwei Jahren wurde der
argentin ja wie eine fußballerische
Lichtgestalt von den Fans in Besitz
genommen sein Abgang dürfte vielen der
psg-anhänger sehr zu Herzen gehen ich
hatte das Privileg den besten Spieler
aller Zeiten zu trainieren
spätestens nach dem WM Triumph ist Messi
in Argentinien zu einem Volkshelden
gereift sein vermuteter Abgang zum
saudischen erstligistenall könnte Messi
mehrere 100 Millionen Euro auf sein
Konto einbringen
Wahnsinn und dann würde ja noch mehr
verdienen als Cristiano Ronaldo der
spielt ja auch in Saudi-Arabien
zum Wetter morgen gibt es wieder vier
Sonne wo aber die Wolken hartnäcke hier
sind das weiß gleich Christa Abend Dunja
liebe Grüße um 21:45 Uhr zum
heute-journal schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend ab heute ist für uns
Meteorologen Sommer und der startete in
der Mitte und im Süden mit viel Sonne im
Norden aber dicht bewölkt jetzt über den
Tag da gab es im Nordosten dann auch die
Sonne in Niedersachsen zum Beispiel
blieb es aber fast den ganzen Tag
bewölkt und so kamen die großen
Temperaturunterschiede zusammen bis 29
Grad am Rhein in Bremerhaven aber nur 13
Grad und mit einem frischen Wind hat
sich das doch eher herbstlich angefühlt
diese kühleren Temperaturen und die
Wolken gehören zu einer Kaltfront die
auch heute Nacht im Norden für bewölkten
Himmel sorgt im Süden ist es klar die
Temperaturen sinken auf 13 bis nur vier
Grad in den westlichen Mittelgebirgen
nachts müssen wir uns also noch warm
anziehen tagsüber gibt es dann die
T-Shirt Temperaturen mit 20 bis 26 Grad
an den Küsten ist es aber deutlich
kühler mit nur 16 bis 19 Grad die Wolken
der Kaltfront liegen morgen vor allem
zwischen dem Emsland und der Lausitz
wenn es daraus mal nieselt lässt das
aber schnell nach nördlich und südlich
davon gibt es wieder viel Sonne bevor
dann abends an den Alpen die Quellwolken
wieder dazu kommen ja und in den
nächsten Tagen gibt es wieder viel Sonne
die Wolkenfelder sind an der Nordsee
häufiger mal dichter die Wolken die
Gewitter an den Alpen werden
wahrscheinlicher es gibt große
Temperaturunterschiede zwischen 15 und
28 Grad